Come on. Totally. You guys can say we
want to talk to you about three. Okay.
Okay, let's do it. Let's do
that. Let's do that then.
Like keep what we can't do. Hey,
this is radiolab I'm Jad Abumrad.
We're going to do something that's
a little bit unorthodox today,
at least for us. Um, you know,
if you've listened to the show
in the last 10 years or so,
however long we've been doing this, uh,
you understand that like we
like to edit, right? We like,
we like a good edit or 70,
but today I want to play you something
that has almost no edits at all.
It's just a conversation which has of
course the foundation of what we do these
long rambling about the occasionally
profane error strewn conversations that we
then edit into something
coherent. But today,
today I want to show you
the messiness, no edits.
This is a chunk of a conversation
with science writer at Carl Zimmer.
He came and sat down with us a while
back and we talked for four hours.
Two of those hours became the
basis for the CRISPR podcast.
That was a few podcasts ago.
This was about gene editing,
but then we kept on going for another
two hours and he told us this story.
Actually two stories,
but we're only gonna play one
that I thought was really cool.
And it's about this new way of looking
at life. This is a, is this a long story,
a medium story or short
story? It's not a, yeah,
we can get through this a lot
faster than CRISPR. Okay. Okay.
I really like CRISPR, by the way.
Who Do I, I mean, CRISPR is, yeah,
it's the bomb. Hmm. Yeah.
That's a perfect way to describe it. Yeah.
By logical bomb. Okay. So, uh, uh,
chapter two can, maybe you can start
the story once, if the
once upon a time. Sure.
So once upon a time being, um,
I'd say once, once upon
a time being before 2003,
we basically had two kinds
of living things on earth.
We had sell your their life and we had
viruses and there was nice and distinct
and clear cut.
And so cells included us.
Our bodies made her cells and
bacteria, which are single celled.
And all the other things that can
grow and let their cells divide.
They have DNA, they have proteins
in them. They all got that stuff.
And then over here you had viruses and
viruses were just little packages of
genetic material that would go from cell
to cell and use the cell to make new
viruses. And so inside of them,
all they had were jeans and a couple of
proteins that would then just sort of
hijack their host. They seem
like soap, soap, preliminary.
They don't even, maybe not
even qualify as life. Right?
They can't grow on their own. Um, they
can't generate their own energy. So,
you know, us and all other
Shangler life, we, um,
we make a kind of a fuel called ATP and
we need that to do every little thing in
our body. And viruses don't
make ATP. So, you know,
they're in shock when we say that life
is us cells and multicellular beings.
And then there's a sort of pseudo life,
which is these little things that live
off of us. Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people,
a lot of scientists don't really
think viruses are truly alive.
Even though they just sort of take
advantage of life to make more copies of
themselves. Okay. Can I say
dumb questions? So viruses,
they don't have a wall around them.
And the way that that cell cells,
our walls essentially
are walled off areas. Um,
they might have a protein
shell. [inaudible] and, and so,
you know, when the flu
virus goes into a cell,
that protein shell kind of breaks open
and the genes and proteins inside come
out. They do have containers that
contain them for, for a while. I see.
Well isn't that one of
the, somebody who had a,
had a list of rules that make you alive
and what wasn't a container was one of
those rules. Yeah. But yeah, I mean
that, that don't do that energy.
But they have the
container at least. Right.
So the problem with viruses is that they
have some of the things that we think
are essential for life,
but not quite all of them.
So it's been convenient just
to say viruses are not alive.
Put them over there cause they don't
have everything that sells really.
Life has. So we'll just say they're not
alive to just viruses. Gotcha. And then,
so then what happened is that there
was a scientist named Timothy Robotham,
uh,
in England who was investigating a
Timothy Robotham Timothy go about them.
Yes. The English name in road Buffum
with the fuck the robot was a,
it was working in Bradford
City in England. And, um,
he was, uh,
looking at the kinds of bacteria
that might be growing in a hospital.
You know,
like there they were having some problems
with pneumonia outbreaks and so on.
And he was like, okay, well what's growing
around here? Uh, and so he went to a,
uh, sort of a cooling tower for
water on top of the hospital,
and he took a sample and he went and put
it under his microscope. And he's like,
hmm, some interesting bacteria here. Oh,
here's a very interesting bacteria that
doesn't really look like anything I've
seen before.
This guy would just kind of crawl
around to weird places and just snatched
little snippets of scum or what
would he, yeah, I mean, was he,
what was his job? He's a microbiologist.
Oh, of course. So you know,
that it would be good to know,
like, I mean some microbiologists,
do they just go scrape little bits
of rock or, or they search the world.
Yeah. I mean microbes are everywhere.
So microbiologists go everywhere to find
microbes. So they're even, you know,
in a water tower on a hospital.
Does he do it? Was he in a,
in a kind of an investigatory
role? He was trying to help them,
help them figure out which bacteria
are making people sick. Um,
that was one of the hopes, but you know,
he was thinking of doing
a survey because you know,
they're diseases like
legionnaires disease, which
can, you know, grow in these,
these sort of containers of
water, you know, that's, there,
there is some concern
about that. So you know,
better to get to know what's growing. Um,
so he's particularly taken by one um,
thing that he assumes is bacteria and
it's got a kind of interesting kind of
roundish shape. Um,
and he calls and when bacteria around
you can call him Cockeye or caucus.
Um, so he names this Bradford
caucus cause it a name.
That's why the caucus name that comes
to me was referring to the shape like
strep streptococcus is,
because it's, it's around my,
I did not know that the things you
learn from talking to Carl Zimmer.
My God. Okay. So, so, um,
so he's, he's trying to study this
thing and he's trying to, so one,
when you're a microbiologist,
the way you study bacteria is you get
them to grow and he can't get this to
grow. He's feeding at things and it's
like smart growing. Why is it not growing?
I can't figure it out. And
eventually, um, you know, he,
he just hits, hits a, it hits
a wall and unfortunately, um,
uh, his lab, uh, got shut down. Um,
and so he basically said,
okay, I don't want to, uh,
throw this stuff out so I'm gonna,
I'm going to give it to some of
my colleagues in France. It was,
it wasn't dying, which wasn't growing.
Yeah. So he gave it to a scientist named
Bernard Lascola and his colleagues
and they kind of put them
and we, and, and he just says, I'm,
he just sets it aside for a
while and doesn't, you know,
it's just more bacteria, you know? And,
and for some reason he
decided to, you know,
take a look at this Bradford
Caucus. You know, I'm like, what?
What was this thing that that
robot them was talking about?
So he looks at it and he
says, okay, it's this,
this is the size of bacteria,
but it looks like a gigantic virus.
You know it. So what is a giant virus
was usually very small. Exactly.
So bacteria to a virus is like,
like hundreds of times bigger,
hundreds of times. Okay.
So queen married too small.
So he looked up close and he
was like, what is this thing?
This doesn't look right. This, this.
If I didn't know better, I'd say this,
this was a virus. And he's saying this
based on its internal orientation.
It's appearance. It's because it
had the protein thingy and stuff.
So a lot of viruses,
they have a shell made a protein and
the shell is kind of composed of plates.
So it's kind kinda looks
like a soccer ball. Uh hmm.
So it's a very distinctive look.
Okay. And it looked like that.
It looked like that. It didn't look like
bacteria. Oh, interesting. I was like,
wait a minute, could this be a virus?
So this would be like maybe like
finding an soccer ball in the woods.
Yes. Two he'd found the, the Leviathan
equivalent of a virus. Right.
It didn't make sense. It was,
it was kind of crazy in that
microscopic realm to say,
maybe this is a virus. Wait, so didn't.
So Brad Mumford, what's his name again?
Timothy Robotham. Robotham didn't
have this realization. Nope.
He hadn't looked at it closely
enough. He looked at it,
but he just didn't somehow put the,
put the this as a virus and click
to the bacteria. No Wednesdays,
that's a virus day and this
was Tuesday. And, and it's,
it's likely that other people were looking
at the same things in years before.
I'm thinking there were bacteria in
there and they're saying, here's a big,
here's something the size of
bacteria. Well, in fairness,
because viruses are always small than the,
that you wouldn't think a big
thing would be fire. Well,
viruses are always small in the sense
that they were discovered because they
were small. So basically signed.
What scientists did was they discovered
viruses by filtering fluid from a sick
plant or a sick animal through
a filter. Porcelain actually,
and it was so small that that anything
besides that bacteria got trapped in the
porcelain and anything smaller came out.
Oh and low and behold they could find
things that could cause sickness in that
fluid that pass through the filter.
Most of the discovery of viruses meant
it was innately small because that's how
you filtered for them. That's what they
were looking for. This is interesting.
So there were probably generations of
scientists who were looking in through
microscopes,
saw some interesting round
thing and assumed it was
bacteria and it was probably
a virus. What the fuck is this
giant, giant Leviathan virus?
I assume that was his
question. Well, I mean,
he first he had to to really
establish that it was,
and so what happened was that, um, he,
he looked very closely at it and
kind of worked at it's chemistry.
And the more he looked at it, the more
it looked like a virus. He started,
he started actually looking at it to
DNA, which hadn't been possible before.
It turned out that its DNA resembled the
DNA of viruses and not have any known
bacteria. Um, it didn't have, it didn't,
it actually didn't have the, the, the
equipment for making fuel inside of it.
Uh, and then the real kicker was
that he found out how to grow it.
What he had to do was he had to stick
this thing inside of Amoeba and then out
of the Amoeba would come
more Bradford Caucus,
just like a virus. Exactly like a virus.
So he needed to change the name from
Bradford Caucus to something else. Right.
So, so they named it Mimi
virus, Mimi virus virus,
because they were in France and me
music in the, in a French shop probably.
But because it was a mimic and he was
mimicking, mimic. Yeah. Interesting. Me,
me, me, me, me, me. Is
that like a French word for Mac?
Um, I think they just took, you know,
the beginning of Mimic
and added it to virus.
Hello. Mimi virus. Very nice. I guess
it's the same thing twice. Me, me.
It's like mimic. Yeah. Okay.
I get it. So interesting.
Yeah. So this, so this was,
I mean this was really bizarre when they
published their report on this in 2003
and men, people really scratch their
head because remember, you know,
ordinary viruses have, you
know, maybe 10 genes. Uh,
this one had a 1080
p and g when you have 10 genes,
those are the genes that,
so you have a protein capsule and
so you can swim through the thing.
So when you land on a cell,
you can borrow in and then explode
and then make babies. So those are,
there's not much to being a virus
and just need a few genes for that.
W thousand.
This does this thing have
particular talents that the
other viruses didn't have.
Maybe it looks like, does it? Oh
it does. What does that, okay.
Well, so what's one thing that's really
interesting is what happens when it goes
inside its host and Amoeba.
It goes in a,
but instead of kind of shedding off that
protein code and just spilling out its
contents,
it actually goes in and stays as it was.
You mean it stays in a container and
everything just sort of, yeah. Oh,
it's called the virus factory.
Once it's inside there,
the that it's this thing they call the
virus factory and it basically is able
to, um, to, to uh, things, you know,
components come into it and then, uh,
then it sort of has enzymes that can
refashion them and then they outcome the
components for new. Yeah.
Yeah. It doesn't have to go into the
nucleus of the already existence. Hell no,
it just floats in there. Oh, interesting.
So it, it, what does it do? Like
[inaudible] portal and
it sucks up some stuff.
Yeah. It has this beautiful sort of a,
they call it a stargate because it's
shaped like it's a doorway shape,
like a star and things
come in. And then I,
I had another stargate, the, the con, the,
these sort of manufactured
things come out.
And then in the cell they
assemble into new giant viruses.
Oh.
So it spits out the raw materials and
that then self assemble into a giant and
giant Leviathan, no baby gentler biases,
which then how do they get out of the,
do they explode through the surface and
blow out? Yeah. That's like a totally,
that's a totally different number. Yeah.
I thought normally viruses just go into
the machine that's already there cause
they're parasites. They just use the
living thing. This thing is, I'm an,
I have a weird kind of a
respect for this thing.
Oh yeah. It's amazing. And you know,
one of the amazing things about it
is that it can get its own viruses.
It gets, there are really, yes.
So there are viruses and viruses.
These things are called Viro phages and
they actually go into virus factory and
high jacket. Oh, interstate
outcome. Viro phages. Oh Wow. Yeah.
As soon as you have a virus
factory, that's what a virus wants.
It's none of the virus has its own
virus factory. Well, it's going to get,
it's going viral infected viral lies by
the other viruses. Right? Weird. Yeah.
Weird is the right word. I think right
now done in 2003 you know, you could say,
well this is one weird virus,
but the scientist said, well hm,
I wonder what else there
is like, did that create a,
wait a second. So they said, okay,
it's got all this extra genetic power,
but he's doing this sort
of special circus act here.
It's building its own factory and it's
just behaving differently for others.
So maybe it just needs all those genes
to do this special thing is doing.
The problem was that when they looked
at these, you know, 1,018 genes,
most of them didn't match anything
anyone had found before. Hmm.
These are new genes. Genes. Yeah.
That you couldn't even guess at what
they were at. This is gotta be from like,
this is like an alien is
from Saturn. This thing,
is that where you're driving with the
story? Not quite, but kind of. I mean,
so waiting. So they look at all
the genes. They look at the,
the chemistry of life as,
as it's known and they don't find
any matches for this little thing,
this big thing for most of the jeans.
They couldn't find a match. Huh? You know,
you can look at, I mean that's a
double mister. Like what is it?
What is this and where does it come from?
Cause it doesn't seem to have
the smell of earth life. Yeah.
Except that it uses DNA. I mean, it
uses protein, it uses our chemistry,
but it's doing something weird. Um,
and so these scientists said, well,
okay, they looked in an English hospital,
you know, water cooling tower,
let's go look at one here in France.
And so they looked and they
found another giant virus,
which is even bigger than the
one that they had already found.
[inaudible] hospital in France,
in the air conditioning. You know,
it was in another cooling
tower. Jesus is like a,
this is a cooling tower phenomenon
so far. Rooftop biology. Well,
it's excitement Galore.
It's more like the drunk looking for
the keys under the lamppost. You know,
it's like, you know, that openness,
wherever you look there, we know that,
we know there was giant viruses
found in one water tower.
So let's go look in another water tower.
Like that's our safest bet and hey
look, we found an even bigger one. Uh,
you know, which they, um, which has
even bigger. It was even bigger. Yeah.
So instead of 1,018
jeans, it had 1,059 genes.
Um, so they named this one mama virus,
Mimi's first cousin Mama. Right, right.
Your Mama duly and things in
the cells that Mimi didn't do,
or did it also built the industry? Yeah,
it was, it was making a virus factory.
So it was like, so there's something,
there's a common theme
here with these two.
Now you have two giant viruses doing
the same thing in the whole stargate and
everything. Uh, yeah. Um,
what's weird is that, you know,
the Mamma virus has a bunch of
genes that Mimi virus doesn't have.
So it's like, and again,
don't match anything that,
so they don't know what
these extra ones do.
Some of them look like they're
involved in building proteins,
which doesn't make any sense because
viruses are not supposed to do that. Huh.
So it's, it's, this is all completely
confusing, Huh? But then they say like,
okay, um,
maybe we need to kind of get away
from the whole water power thing and,
you know, widen our a
little, where would you go?
Like to the opposite of a water tower
would be like the bottom of a well,
or is it or do you go to a library and
look in the interior of old parchment
books? Now you start looking
at places like 'em you look,
you look in the ocean or you look in
sediment or you look inside animals,
um, or,
or you look in the soil and they start
finding giant viruses over and over and
over again. Really? Yeah. In all of
those places. In oil, inside of animals,
like in animals, tummies or
something. Yeah. So, um, they, uh,
they went to, um, these,
these researchers went to Brazil and said,
let's go look at animals and see
if we can find giant viruses.
And they found a new species in cows and
they found a new species living inside
of a monkey. And these were,
were they finding giant
or giant viruses? I mean,
the numbers of genes were
going up and up and they would,
they would keep finding new
record breakers. So, so the,
the biggest one right
now is called mega virus
virus. I mean, there's, you know,
the mega in a world you
got it. That's right.
It's like the truck of sorts. You
know, I was like, this is like, I, I,
I'm wondering what they're gonna do as
they keep finding bigger ones because you
keep on having to find
Sapelo for these days. Well,
where was mega found and where
it was workers? Meg, I believe,
was found in the ocean. And
how many genes does mega have?
Mega has a 1000,
120 genes. Okay. So, but
it's not actually the big,
so it has the most jeans,
but it's not actually that physically
the biggest giant virus, which was,
so this, this one is a
called a Pandora virus
in a box, in a sealed box.
And then I opened it
and well, it's shaped,
it has this bizarre
shaped like an earn a Ho,
which is completely nuts.
There's no urn shaped, viral,
crazy. And the earn.
Does that remind somebody of the myth of
Pandora's box was actually an earn? Oh,
it was? Okay. Oh, I see. Why is it
be called Pandora's box then? God,
this is a very list to make you happy
because you love where they found it.
Where did they find it? So what they
did, uh, these Russian scientists,
they were collaborating with dug up
frozen Tundra that had been frozen for
30,000 years. And they said, let's
throw this out and see what's in there.
What kind of things had been
asleep for 30,000 years?
And it sounds like the beginning
of the Psi Phi movie right there,
among other things, they found pendulum
screws. They found Pandora virus.
Huh? And they, not only
did they find it, but they,
when they let it warm up a bit, uh,
and then they gave it some amoeba
checkout. They, they did it.
They did its thing. Wow.
And it w how much bigger if the first a
giant virus introduced us to was like an
elephant sized mouse.
It compared to that elephant size
mouse. How much bigger is this one?
Um, maybe it's more specific than you
might be. I need to look at the numbers,
but you know, you're kind of going from,
I don't know, elephants to dinosaurs.
You're getting bigger and bigger
and bigger. You're, uh, you know,
we're not talking about, you know,
Pandora virus is bigger
than a lot of bacteria. Wow.
So these things are now being
found everywhere. You look. I mean,
they are incredibly common.
They've even been able to get giant
viruses out of people. Really? Yeah.
We deal with where are you find them
in a person and our intestines or
something. Um,
I believe they found one
sample in somebody's lungs. Um,
and another sample was
found in someone's blood,
but it's really hard to tell whether
they're actually like actively invading us
and making us sick. You know,
maybe seven reading Amoebas,
they can invade human cells cause maybe
on human cells are surprisingly similar.
Um,
or is it just kind of along for the
ride with some Amoeba that infect us?
Um, or does it kind of drift
in and when people are sick,
their defenses are down.
So we don't know if giant viruses have
anything to do with human disease. But
you have a category problem here.
If you've got a giant virus that's virus
like in it's general shell but it's
making proteins,
it's got a bunch of genes
that viruses don't have.
You're already bigger than
some bacteria shouldn't be,
call it as its own separate thing at
this point. That's what people are,
are arguing about right now. I mean do,
do we keep that line between viruses
and cellular life and just put the giant
viruses with the viruses or do
we kind of blur the line a bit?
This feels like it's on its way from
one category to the other. So that's,
that's one of the big questions is
like what way did this thing go?
And evolution, what does that mean?
Well, how do you get a giant virus?
Like how do you, how do you, well that so,
so we'll get to the potential
answer to that question,
which I think is totally fascinating.
After the break.
Hi there. This is Kirsten
recording from Orlando, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
[inaudible]
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by wordpress.com
wordpress.com offers e-commerce options
that range from effective buy button to
a complete online store as well as code
free site building.
So you don't need a professional designer
to get your website up and running if
you need help.
Wordpress has a customer support team
that is available 24 seven learn more and
get 15% off any new pen purchase
at wordpress.com/radiolab
okay.
Radiolab is supported by swell
investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got?
Invest in our planet while also
investing in your financial future.
Think about that. Our resources are
diminishing. Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest
challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth
companies working towards clean water when
usable energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity
you can feel good about.
You get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab
in the moments before Charles Kinsey
was shot by police in summer 2016 he
pleaded with the autistic man next
to him to lie down. Please lie down.
Then the cell phone video cuts.
I'm Audrey Quinn after effect is a
new podcast from w n y c studios.
We tell the story behind the
shooting and what happened next.
Listen and subscribe to after effect
wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, Jad here. Radio labs,
so we're going to return
to our conversation with
science writer Carl Zimmer.
It's an unedited conversation. And A,
we were talking about giant viruses
and what they can teach us about life,
which really starts with a
simpler question of like,
where the hell did they come from?
How do you get a giant fires? Like how
do you, how do you, well that and so,
so one clue comes from those jeans.
So now that they're finding more
and more of these giant viruses,
they're finding enough, a
variety of them. They can,
they can look for a serious and some
common genes that they share some,
some common mutations in genes.
And they're finding actually that,
that it looks like giant viruses
might actually belong to one lineage.
Oh, interesting. Sure. Their cousins,
they have a common ancestor. Yeah.
So this tribe of us, right.
And if that, if that's true,
it could be an incredibly
old tribe. These,
these giant viruses could
be a lineage, conceivably,
that goes all the way back to,
you know, the stages of life,
the dawn of time in order. It's really,
oh, like I went back to the very beginning
of life on earth, um, to that era.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean maybe
when cellular life was getting
started, but the question is, well,
what were the giant viruses like then?
Now some people have said, well no,
giant virus is actually started out as
teeny tiny viruses and they've just been
like gathering up new genes through
time and just been getting bigger and
bigger, bigger. Um, but you know,
a number of the people who actually
study giant viruses and have really,
you know, helped us to understand
the most are saying, no,
we don't think so.
We actually think that these things
started out as cellular life.
They were cells, they
were full blown cells.
Oh, you mean they were from the other
side of the road? They were cellular life.
And then what? They switched sides.
They changed teams. Yeah. How,
how to know that like I can't have
a plant that becomes an animal.
How did they, so they started off as
like what we would call creatures,
right. And then they started
out truly alive. You know, they,
they for you standing out there in the
air or the water or the ground or just
some like some free living microbe.
Yeah. And then that could be,
why would they be, why would
you go demoed yourself? This is,
this is your problem with parasites.
You keep saying mean things
about parasites. Well,
how am I here that we've been talking
about parasites taught you nothing.
If I have a choice
between being ace intake,
having my own integrity and choosing to
make a living on my own or to suck off
you, I would just live on
my own. Excuse me for no,
you like parasites, but
honestly could you not use that?
That passage in the recording
actually it's already been cut of.
So say wait a second. So you,
according to this theory you
have a man's true. Nevertheless,
we have a micro that is,
that is doing its thing and then
something happens. What is the something?
It becomes a parasite.
It becomes a parish or at least you know
maybe a symbiotic here. They basically,
what it does is it starts
living inside another cell.
You need gives up its
integrity as a, as a,
as a free life form of
free standing life form.
Just so we understand what that means.
That means that it's got a shell,
it's got a border, it's
making its own energy.
It's replicating in the way that
let the beginning at the beginning,
at the beginning, it can make its own
energy. It can grow, it can divide,
they can do all the things
that living things do. Yeah.
And then for some reason it chooses to
require some other creatures existence
for it's own. It has,
it has to become dependent on
some other organism for its very,
very existence. Well, let's flip
it the other way. Say it discovers
a wonderful new home inside
of another cell. It says,
it comes in and it's like, just like,
I love leaving my park off in new
apartment for a dark cave and exciting
opportunity. No, no, no. Oh, contrare
AU. Contraire like imagine, imagine you.
Like let's say, let's imagine
you're like bear Grylls. Okay.
Let's imagine you are like hiking
around and killing your own food.
Okay, let's, let's try to picture
this. Okay, Robert, doing this.
You're gutting your deer.
You're starting your own fires.
You're going on and on and on.
And you do that for like a few years and
then you're walking through the jungle
and then very, very skinny
cause it's not going well.
So Robert Krulwich that
the haggard hunter, um,
and let's say you're doing this in
Minnesota, right? So it's like cold. Okay.
And then suddenly like you, you,
there's a break in the forest and you
come across a giant mansion and you're
like, what is this place?
And you open the door and inside there's
like conveyor belts with ice cream and
steak and you know, and,
and there are slippers waiting for
you and you know, anything you need,
it's somebody else's taken care of
it. There is one thing you left out.
When I walk into this magical
kingdom, it doesn't let me out.
I can't leave ever again. Sure.
You can become so dependent on its natural
wonders that I lose my independence,
my integrity and the very, very thing
that I walked in with is now gone.
We did literally have this conversation
a few years ago. We did. It's true.
We did.
And I did point out to you at the time
that you are quite dependent on on other
species. Do you want me to
bring, yeah, no, no, no,
no. But I will just,
I would just say see episode 32 droughts,
eyes will rule right out of their
sockets. So, so like becoming big,
being able to take
advantage of another cell,
evolutionarily speaking is,
is a great way to go because you have
all these things taken care of for you.
Now. Um, the, the, according
to this theory, these,
these mysterious, ancient, uh,
microbes started going into these cells
and reproducing there and then going out
again and then finding another host cell
to infect. Okay. Were they making like,
um, where they making their hosts
sick? Uh, probably, yeah, probably.
Yeah, because giant viruses are not
good to get. Let's see. This is,
this complicates your mentioned metaphor
just a tiny bit because what it means
is that you go in the conveyor belt swirl
and you're feeding yourself and having
a good time,
but then your filth starts to muck up
the place and it starts to collapse from
within. That doesn't sound so nice.
Strain the metaphor bed boy, go boy,
Robert Frank to me, me now it's to go
to him. Okay, I understand. So, so you,
you spend some time in this wonderful
mansion. You, you rest, it's warm,
it's comfortable selling you,
you, you eat with your filth,
you start a family, you know,
and then all of a sudden you
and your descendants, you know,
leave the mansion.
The mansion just collapses from
all the damage you did to it.
But you know, actually you see in
the distance there's another mansion.
Let's just go over there and now you feel
like rested and ready and like, yeah,
that all we gotta do is get over
there. So let's just go there.
We don't have to, we don't have
to stop to, to kill a deer.
We just go to that next mansion. The ice
cream is waiting. I still got to walk.
So I need my legs so to speak, to
get to the next mansion. Right.
But I don't need the powerful muscles
that I would have needed to kill the deer.
I can let you don't even, you
don't need even need, you know,
let's say that you're, you know,
you don't even need the knowledge of
how to kill a deer, wouldn't be blind,
dumb and fat. So these are these things,
these things turn these
things they get rid of,
they start getting rid of these jeans
and, and how does that happen? Just,
you know, a random mutation comes
along and just cuts out a bit of DNA.
She doesn't need them. You're fine.
Yeah. You're like, no, that's okay.
Is it a moment where, oh, there
goes a big chunk of me gone. Yeah.
I don't need that.
That's a regular kind of mutation that
happens all the time really in sales.
Oh yeah, yeah. But then you're, you're,
your successor being just travels a
little bit lighter and is able to succeed
just as well. Right. So, you
know, if, if, if, if, you know,
if we are born, you know, with, with
a part of our DNA that's deleted,
that had some, you know,
like hemoglobin genes in it,
like goodnight, like that's
bad. I mean, but um, you know,
but if you cut out a gene that this giant
virus no longer needs because it's got
everything supplied to
it and its host fine.
So chuck that chuck it
out. So you have this,
so the idea is that you have these
viruses, they're giant viruses,
but they're actually been shrinking. Huh?
And at a how fast does a giant,
like the g imagining back
in the beginning there was,
there was not mega, not giant. No. In
the beginning it was a cellular B. Oh,
cellular. Right. Okay. So this, I mean,
privileges independent life size wise,
it's a blimp. It's a massive thing.
And then suddenly it starts to
shrink bit by bit by bit by bit.
What at what rate does it start
to shrink and shed itself? Well,
it could be that these giant viruses,
we're finding these giant viruses that
scientists are finding could be shrinking
very, very, very slowly. It could be that
there are other viruses that made
this transition that shrank faster.
So maybe, maybe it's a race to
the bottom, maybe some, some,
maybe some tiny viruses or
just former giant viruses
that just shrank really fast.
Race to the bottom. It's sure.
Different way of thinking about life. You,
you generally assume being a
multicellular organism yourself. Yeah,
that little things in
some deep sense though.
You're not supposed to say
this. I want to be big things.
You don't want to say
this. I know, I know.
But most people unlike you asshole,
most people think that
it's better to be more
complex than to be simple.
But here you're talking about
a different voyage altogether.
It might just work out for you
to be simple rather than complex.
Um, well, given that, that viruses
are insanely abundant on this planet,
I mean there are by some estimates a
10 to the 31st power viruses on earth.
I think about that. Like
it's a, it's a, you know,
it's a one with 31 zeros after it.
I mean it's inconceivable how
many viruses there are on earth.
So it's their world. So
apparently, you know,
nature has not agreed with you, but
you know, it is interesting like, uh,
thinking about how, how
life gets smaller and
simpler. Yeah. It's interesting. Yeah.
If it's true that this trajectory is as,
as, as common as you say,
that that things start out sometimes start
out big and then learn to live inside
other things and in the process get
smaller and smaller and smaller.
And this is actually maybe what
happens to a lot of viruses,
not just sound viruses in a way it
gives the virus and honorable history.
I don't know.
I feel that way else. This boy
isn't going to sign up for nothing.
He's not going to sign up for that. And
then I don't know. It's okay. I will
an honorable history, but then I mean
it abandoned it's free living path,
right? It did.
It gave into the temptations of the
mansion full of steak and ice cream. Yeah,
it's true. But yeah,
always assumed, and this is not,
not something wants you to seem that
viruses were a kind of prodo organism.
They were somehow at the beginning of
something and they never quite got going.
Yeah. But this,
you're actually saying that these
viruses are in a way at the end,
not at the end, but they're at the,
I don't know how to quite use the
words that I want to use this.
They feel somehow at the end of
something, not at the beginning,
like you've just took the,
you just took what I considered to be
the beginning and you've now made it an
and an end and end. And
that's interesting. I never,
that's very interesting.
Yeah. Very interesting. So, so life
can go in different directions.
Okay. And how far can that journey
go? I mean, can you go from
like how big did that it,
was it ever like a turtle with,
with uh, with things or no,
like a giant dinosaur? No, no,
sorry. Yeah. There are things called,
I believe they're called mixes zones, um,
which started out as free living
animals and have become parasites.
And they're just down to just
a few cells, maybe mixed zones.
You say we didn't free living animals.
You don't mean animals in the way that
animals that anyone would think of an
animal like a jelly. Oh look, my pet
and my pet fluffy. Not like that.
Well my pet jellyfish.
Really? Really? Yeah.
So you're saying a jellyfish size thing
has now reduced itself to a tiny spec
microscopic parasite of fish. Get The for,
I won't even say it because you can't do
it if you're that small. That's insane.
It really,
it's like going from something you
can see and would want to avoid while
swimming down to something that you
might even just breathe in without even
knowing it. [inaudible] wow.
Oh, you're blowing my mind.
Shrinking my, what was it
called again? Mixes. Mixes.
Zone mixes zone. Yeah.
How do you spell that?
M Y. X. Z. O. H. N.
I'm trying in my mind to construct a
scenario where we like the mix zone could
begin to shed. Like if we
were living inside the,
like not the iPhone but the I I own
the I universe. Well, you know, but,
but the fact is that we, you know, we
have cast aside some things, you know,
what have we cast to say? Well we
can't, I mean we used to smell better.
I know that. I knew that
I felt better. Yeah.
We used to be able to make our
own vitamin C in our own bodies.
Our own bodies were vitamin C
factories. Really? Yes. Wait, what,
what changed that? Probably did we want
to let go of that? That sounds great.
Sunshine, vitamin C, yeah. Making your
own supply of vitamin C. Well, um,
if you are sitting around eating
fruit all the time, fruit,
which is loaded in vitamin C,
then if you get a mutation
on your vitamin C gene,
well in Europe you're fine
cause you, you're, you,
you're getting your vitamins c from
somewhere else. You don't feel that lack,
you know,
C and you don't start getting scurvy
because you're treating yourself on fruit.
And then that mutated gene may then spread
out and end up being in every member
of your species, which
seems to happen to us.
I mean you can literally
like see like these,
we have these broken vitamin C genes.
So sometimes we shrink to, yeah.
[inaudible]
okay. So there you have it.
A raw conversation with science writer
Carl Zimmer about shrinking shrinkage in
life. No, usually what happens
these conversations is uh,
cause you're just talking and cause you
don't really have like an encyclopedia
sitting right next to you. You get a
lot of a little things wrong details,
little facts, names, dates,
whatever. And then you know,
you fact check it later.
Uh, so in fairness to Carl,
as we were fact checking,
we gave him the chance to listen
back to the raw conversation,
make a couple of amendments.
This is fact checker.
Caro a scolding rambling Carl.
Okay. So, okay, we were saying that, um,
this is microbiologist, uh, Tim
Robotham took his samples to France,
but actually there was
another microbiologist named
Richard Bertles that did it.
Um, Gotcha. Small but important. Sorry
Richard. My, our apologies. Yeah.
And Mama virus turns out to
have a thousand, 23 genes,
not 1,059 genes going. Apologies. Then
I started talking about echo virus.
At the time in 2011,
it was indeed the biggest
virus known 1000, 120 genes.
Okay. Okay. However,
there was in 2013 a another virus found,
um, called Pandora virus.
Now I was saying that this was something
found this had Green Tundra wrong.
This was found the ocean and
this virus has oh lot of genes.
How many I had has 2,500. Whoa.
2,500. I mean, that's way
more than a lot of bacteria.
Also a it at a certain point.
And we do refer to Pandora virus as
being the biggest virus in size actually.
That uh, that distinction
goes to hippo virus. And, uh,
also it seems that since we talked,
there's evidence that there might
actually be a couple separate lineages of
giant viruses.
One may have evolved from big
to small as we talked about,
but another one might have gone in
the usual direction from small to big.
Um, there's one last thing
that I see. So apparently, uh,
apparently I didn't quite
spell mixes zone correct.
This is how you spell mixes
zone. M Y, X. O. Z. O. A. N.
Apparently I missed one of those.
Those I can remember. I mean,
I would be lying if I say I didn't
think a little bit less of, you know.
Okay. Extra. Oh, back in the raw stupidity
that goes into radio lab. Yeah. Stupid
people interviewing stupid people
about smart things. That's funny.
That's a great taglines, dude.
Okay. Uh, that's our new
tagline. I'm Chad IPM. Rod,
thanks for listening.
This is James Jordan from Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Radiolab is produced by Jad ABIM Rod.
Our staff includes Brenna Farrell,
Ellen Horn, David Gable, Dylan Keith,
Matt kilty, Andy Mills, Latif,
Nasser Kelsey Padgett, Ariane whack,
Molly Webster, Soren Wheeler, and Jamie
York with help from Dmiano Marchetti,
Molly McBride, Jacobson
and Alexandra Leon.
Our fact checkers are if a
Dasher and Michelle Harris.
Okay.